not the return to school the government
wanted ministers forced to deviate from
their roadmap to get all primary school
kids back into classrooms before the
summer holidays when our we're not able
to welcome all primary children back for
a full month before the summer we
continued to work with a sector on the
next steps we will be working to bring
all children back to school in September
if the government had brought together
everyone involved in implementing these
plans from the outset and really taken
onboard what they had to say they would
not be in the situation of having to
roll back at all children and young
people's education and well-being will
have been impacted cruelly by such a
prolonged period away from school
the government's ambition was to get all
primary school kids back into school for
at least four weeks before the summer
holidays but the need to keep class
sizes down means schools like this
simply don't have the space education on
a back burner then as the government
prioritized the health crisis and now an
economic one but soon they'll be
counting the social cost of millions
missing out on their education the fact
not lost on this conservative Select
Committee Chair we campaign for pubs and
shops and businesses to open and
football matches to start and yet it is
so difficult to reopen our schools we
know that something like 85% of
vulnerable children are not going to
school at the moment the longer the
schools remain closed the more we are
damaging the life chances of these
younger children are particularly isn't
the problem that you can't have the
children back into school if you have to
have two metres of social distance if
you have to balance those risks with
also the risks of not attending school
and the damage that it's doing to
potentially to children's futures
school's out for summer and the
September at an still a target not a
guarantee a country already with big
educational divides between the rich and
the poor and a gap set to widen in the
absence of any clear
government plan beth rigby sky news
westminster